et ça peut prendre des formes tout à
fait variable suivant les chamans
certains vont se lancer à fond
crier sauter avoir l'air de se
transformer pour d'autres ça va être
beaucoup plus mesurée ça va demeurer un
champ avec une versification extrêmement
maîtrisé merci beaucoup en tout cas
charles stefanov d'avoir participé à
ceux des deux rives du dogue cette
émission est à revoir sur notre site
rt france point tv à découvrir également
en podcast merci pour votre fidélité à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'actionnaire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
donald trump privé de son outil de
communication favori twitter suspense on
compte de façon permanente le réseau
social met en avant le risque de
nouvelles incitations à la violence
le président sortant dénonce un
musellement de la liberté d'expression
donald trump par ailleurs
potentiellement sous le coup d'une
nouvelle procédure de destitution
[Musique]
le variant britannique ducobu 19 suscite
l'inquiétude en france 21 nouveaux cas
viennent d'être un détecté près de
marseille dans une même famille il
s'ajoute à la vingtaine de cas déjà
recensés sur le territoire notamment
dans les hauts-de-seine à bagneux qui
depuis ce matin des pistes massivement
sa population une souche plus
contagieuse conséquence la liste ne
cesse de s'allonger
des nouveaux départements qui voient
leur couvre feu avancée dès 18 heures
[Musique]
les images largement relayée aux chocs
et celle de tentes déchirées et lacéré
lors d'une évacuation d'un camp de
migrants à grandissante dans la région
des hauts de france a les conditions
climatiques y sont rudes avec l'hiver
les associations des deux exilés
réclament l'instauration d'un dispositif
grand froid pour les mettre à l'abri
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france à onze jours de
la fin de son mandat donald trump
pourrait faire l'objet d'une nouvelle
procédure de destitution pour incitation
à l'insurrection trois jours après les
violences du capita du capitole à les
démocrates à affûtent leurs armes leur
chef nenci pelosi dit vouloir mettre à
l'écart à un président déséquilibré
donald trump qui voit son compte twitter
suspendu de façon permanente
walid bennani un point presse qui
restera dans les livres d'histoire
la présidente démocrate de la chambre
des représentants appelle une nouvelle
fois à une décision irrévocable
le seuil franchi et d'une telle gravité
qu'il n'est pas question que ce
président soit autorisé à prendre des
décisions ni même à mobiliser la moindre
trouble de ses trains piste et
maintenant que va-t-il se passer
aujourd'hui
qui sait mais ce que nous savons c'est
qu'il doit être maîtrisée où la hausse
tout comme fin 2019 les démocrates
invoque le 25e amendement de la
constitution américaine
le comportement de donald trump décrié
après son discours musclé devant ses
supporters et les manifestations qui ont
suivi à washington au sein du capitole
jeudi depuis maintenant bien plus d'un
an qu'il n'est pas apte à servir qu'il
n'est pas apte à servir
c'est l'un des présidents les plus
incompétents de l'histoire des états
unis d'amérique
la question est de savoir aujourd'hui ce
qui va se passer les 14 ou 13 prochains
jours d'être clé le 20 janvier jour où
le président élu joe biden prêtera
serment d'ici cette date
donald trump est capable de prendre des
décisions importantes
il a annoncé ne pas vouloir assister à
la prochaine passation du pouvoir
une première pour un président américain
depuis 1869 annonce faite par le
milliardaire républicain sur twitter
vendredi le réseau social inquiets des
conséquences de ces décès
lyon a donc décidé d'exclure de façon
permanente
l'homme aux 88 millions d'abonnés après
avoir examiné de près les récentes 8 du
comte de donald trump et le contexte qui
les entoure en particulier la façon dont
ils sont reçus et interprétés sur
twitter et en dehors
nous avons suspendu définitivement le
compte en raison du risque de nouvelles
incitations à la violence après les
évènements du mercredi 6 janvier qui ont
fait cinq morts
le ministère de la justice a annoncé 15
inculpation dans celle de richard bach
n'être parvenu à s'introduire dans les
bureaux de la présidente de la chambre
des représentants alors que le parlement
validé dans le même temps la victoire de
joe biden l'homme inculpé pour intrusion
violente
d'autres arrestations sont à prévoir a
annoncé le bureau du procureur fédéral
de washington
drapeau du capitole en berne nancy
pelosi a confié également s'être
entretenu avec l'armée américaine pour
s'assurer que donald trump ne puisse pas
utiliser les précieux code nucléaire
[Applaudissements]
et on dit donald trump de plus en plus
isolé les t-il donc ça écouter ce qu'on
pense drieu godefridi auteur du livre
comment l'amérique un jean plus siècle
la loyauté l'électorat républicain à
l'égard de cette figure quand ils
viennent sans viega dans le quartier les
militants il re qui a toujours rêvé
d'ailleurs depuis qu'il est candidat
entend incarner sa candidature
aujourd'hui qu'un séjour est vexant
départ à ceux dont la force du nombre
à l'heure actuelle reste clairement dans
le camp d'autres heures et non pas celui
de la lega le parti républicain faut pas
oublier que dans le système américain
wallemme il y attraper les prix d'un
donc lorsque vous avez un candidat qui
ait choisi par l'établissement
républicain il est possible que
quelqu'un se présentant contre lui
pendant que le comme des buts l'élection
proprement dit et donc si vous avez une
base n'était pas en plus nombreux ce qui
va pousser des candidats toutes les
primaires républicaines
ils garderont la maîtrise du parti et
lucas pas question aujourd'hui est de
savoir s'il existe encore électoralement
parlant à un parti républicain au delà
et en dehors de la figure d'autres
rumeurs je n'en suis pas convaincu
à l'heure actuelle seuls les états unis
qui menaçaient pas la corée du nord à
quelques jours de la prise de fonction
de john dryden kim jong-un affirme que
les états unis sont le plus grand ennemi
de son pays
à quelle que soit la personne au pouvoir
la vraie nature de sa politique contre
la corée du nord ne va jamais changer
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le dirigeant
nord-coréen lors du 8ème congrès du
parti au pouvoir
kim jong-un qui assure par ailleurs que
pyongyang va se
doté d'un sous marin nucléaire autant de
propos perçue comme une provocation à
l'adresse de la nouvelle administration
américaine
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques jean vincent brisset
revient sur les intentions de kim
jong-un a dans les faits la progression
des forces nucléaires nord-coréennes
elle cette progression totalement
illégal avait pu avoir lieu en toute
liberté
pendant les huit ans la présidence obama
elle a été entièrement stoppée pendant
la présidence trump est à l'heure
actuelle si brown qui a des échéances
internes en profite profitent de
l'affaiblissement fin de la disparition
d'un pouvoir politique aux états unis
pendant au moins quelques jours et de
l'espoir de prouver quelque chose
d'aussi faible vis-à-vis de lui qu'elle
était la présidence obama pour
recommencer dans son système de chantage
et d'obtention d'un certain nombre de
privilèges et d'absence de sanctions en
échange d'un âge sont âge au nucléaire
elle ne va rien britannique ducobu 19
identifiés en catalogne
l'espagne qui fait face à la pandémie et
adapte les lieux culturels fermé il lui
faut trouver d'autres alternatives
barcelone ainsi organisé un concert test
une expérience réalisée à me descendre
en intérieur et qui a réuni près de 500
personnes dans le respect d'un protocole
sanitaires très strictes
aucun cas de contamination n'a été
détecté une réussite qui pourrait bien
donner des idées
reportage de l'esc lessing la plus de
450 participants et aucun cas de corona
virus détectés par la suite c'est le
résultat de ce concert test qui s'est
déroulé à barcelone alors plus qu'un
événement c'est un véritable essai
clinique qui a été rigoureusement
orchestrée alors tout a été organisé par
un festival musical le prix mais varas
hand est un hôpital catalan le rendez
vous était donné dans une salle de
concert les participants avaient entre
18 et 59 ans les conditions étaient
qu'il soit en bonne santé et qu'ils ne
vivent pas sous le même toit qu'une
personne âgée alors le jour même sur
place une équipe médicale été chargé
d'effectuer les tests antigénique puis à
l'intérieur une série de mesure était
appliquée alors tous les participants
devaient porter un masque homologues
ffp2 une zone de bach était le seul
endroit où il était possible de
consommer et donc la seule zone où il
était possible de baisser son masque la
ventilation et la température ont
également été optimisée du début à la
fin et en revanche aucune distance
sociale n'était demandé le public
pouvait danser et chanter alors les
organisateurs se disent très satisfaits
de cette expérience et il explique que
l'étude pourrait être d'une grande
utilité pour organiser à nouveau des
événements de grande ampleur et
direction maintenant le royaume uni qui
dépasse les trois millions 2,99 et les
80 mille morts l'épidémie est hors de
contrôle selon le maire de londres
pays le plus endeuillé d'europe le
royaume uni a vécu hier sa journée la
plus meurtrière depuis le début de la
pandémie 1325 morts en 24 heures
les hôpitaux sont submergés comment
expliquer une telle situation
elle nous avons posé la question à
philippe froguel il est chercheur et
professeur à londres les hôpitaux sont
vraiment dépassé dans les hôpitaux de
mon université dans l'ouest de londres
on avait déjà la semaine dernière plus
de patients que lors du premier pic de
la première vague
donc c'est vraiment vraiment très très
catastrophique
le système britannique est déjà un
système de un peu rapidement saturés
parce qu'il ya moins de lits kankankan
france ou qu'en encore entend moins
qu'en allemagne et déjà l'hiver est
souvent des problèmes et là on est
vraiment vraiment dans la très très très
grosses difficultés
y'a pas assez d'infirmières il n'y a pas
assez de médecins pour faire face à
l'afflux de malades c'est ça le problème
aujourd'hui il ya des nouveaux hôpitaux
spécial spécialisé sur le break sur le
but vide qui ont ouvert mais ils sont
vite parce qu'il n'y a pas de médecin et
le variant britannique ducobu 19 ans qui
est aussi beaucoup en france 21 nouveaux
cas viennent d'être détectée dans un
cluster familial près de marseille
ils s'ajoutent aux dix neuf cas déjà
identifiés sur le territoire à bagneux
dans les hauts-de-seine une vaste
campagne de dépistage est organisé
depuis ce matin après la découverte d'un
cas dans une école maternelle de la
ville les autorités appellent les
habitants a effectué un test pcr pour
déterminer la circulation active ou non
de cette nouvelle souche du virus
la campagne se poursuit jusqu'à mardi je
vous propose d'écouter la maire de
bagneux là le centre a ouvert donc de
dépistage a ouvert à 10 heures comme
comme convenu il y avait déjà beaucoup
d'affluence de balnéo l'aise et balnéo
l'est beaucoup de familles aussi sont à
noter avec avec leurs enfants
voilà l'organisation avec l' agence
régionale de santé et l'ap-hp ans et les
personnels de l'ap-hp
voilà et très opérationnelle bien sûr il
ya un petit peu que mais voilà ça se
passe de manière correcte et apaisée
comme vous avez pu le voir en arrivant
et donc les habitants ont bien compris
je crois l'enjeu du dépistage donc on a
un cas
de kovy de souche britannique donc sur
la commune dans le personnel de la
commune et donc les habitants ont
compris l'intérêt en fait de venir se
faire dépister pour se protéger eux
mêmes bien sûr protéger les leurs et
puis aussi finalement protéger les
autres et les regards à présent de marie
giraud héraud elle est vice-présidente
du collectif sont est en danger on voit
qu'on a deux mois de décalage avec des
courbes anglaise
donc ça a commencé q3 là bas donc on
peut s'attendre à voir une forte
augmentation si le variante circulent il
est déjà sur le territoire
si les enfants sont plus de lecteurs
effectivement il faudra peut-être plus
il des pistes et on a vu que
l'angleterre a décidé de fermer des
écoles en début de semaine c'est une
piste qu'ils ont prise
il faudra suivre ça de très près dans
nos écoles à une nouvelle variante qui
est plus agressive donc il faudra
sûrement un petit peu durcira des choses
il faut toujours rappeler qu'on
fonctionne en fonction de mes décisions
par rapport à l'attention du talent hier
c'est le seul critère qui nous pousse à
prendre ce genre de décisions l'hôpital
est en tension les leaders et à son
saturé
si les livrets à étaient plus disponible
si le personnel soignant aurait été plus
libre aussi on aurait moins de tensions
sociétales moines de mesures sanitaires
à prendre et confrontés à cette menace
du variant britannique le gouvernement
avance le couvre feu dont huit nouveaux
départements en plus des 15 déjà
concernés par la mesure depuis une
semaine dès demain il commencera donc à
18 heures au lieu de 20 heures dans les
bouches du rhône le haut et le bas rhin
le cheikh l'allier
la côte d'or le vaucluse et les alpes de
haute provence un choix en dépit de
l'opposition de certains élus locaux
auprès du préfet je me suis opposée
comme michel rubi ball à martine vassal
et l'ensemble des élus à l'extension du
couvre-feu à 18 heures pour les bouches
du rhône
aucunes données épidémiologiques ne
garantie de résultats sur la propagation
du coït 19 et les critères change en
permanence et dans ce contexte le
gouvernement promet une accélération de
la campagne de vaccination l'eau cap des
200 milles vacciner devrait être franchi
ce week-end selon olivier ferrand
le ministre de la santé en visite dans
un centre de vaccination à tarbes au
côté du premier ministre jean castex
il a également annoncé que les premières
doses du vaccin moderna le deuxième
autorisée en france seront livrés dès
lundi il hier déjà pas loin de 40 milles
entre 35 et 40 mille français ont été
vaccinés la semaine prochaine lors dans
le week-end la vaccination se poursuit
d'ailleurs exemple ici à à tarbes
mais la semaine prochaine le rythme
augmentera encore et vous verrez que
nous serons nous sommes déjà dans la
moyenne journalière des pays européens
et nous nous prendrons évidemment un
rythme plus important encore non pas
pour se dire qu'il faut aller absolument
le plus vite possible mais parce que les
moyens qui sont mis en place le
permettent de manière à protéger un
maximum de français nous passerons donc
probablement le cap symbolique des cent
mille français vaccinés dans le week-end
et nous accentuerons à partir de la
semaine prochaine les endroits où ça va
très vite et nous dise
ramenez-nous des vaccins ça va aller
vite seront fournis toutes les semaines
en vaccins à mesure que ces vaccins sont
fournies à la france par les différents
laboratoires
je rappelle 500000 vaccins seront
alloués à la france
en supplément la semaine prochaine puis
la semaine d'après pour le vaccin de
pfizer et nous aurons 50 mille premières
doses du nouveau vaccin qui dont le
fonctionnement est identique et
labellisation est identique
le vaccin moderna à partir de lundi dans
notre pays ce qui permettra également
d'augmenter les quantités de vaccins
disponibles
un mof de cette manifestation de gilet
jaune aujourd'hui ils étaient une
centaine dans les rues de lyon
une mobilisation globalement plus
faibles pour cet acte 113 du mouvement
un autre défilé dans le centre de paris
s'est déroulée dans le calme encadrés
par un important dispositif de sécurité
des jeux les jeunes se sont également
réunis devant la maison de la radio et
la tour tf1 pour protester contre les
médias
on veut dire haut et fort à la au média
et au gouvernement que les gilet jaune
vert
on n'est pas des complotistes on n'est
pas des malades mentaux
on est des mêmes les malades mentaux en
droit de s'exprimer et pour le coup là
on est des personnes qui travaillons
pour le pour la france et pour le bien
commun et nous voulons dire que les
médias publics doivent appartenir à la
population nous avons le droit de nous
exprimer sur les médias on n'a pas à
devoir tous les samedis depuis deux ans
marchez dans la rue pour devoir dire nos
solutions et nos revendications et autre
manifestation ce samedi dans plusieurs
villes de l'hexagone cette fois-ci de
plusieurs milliers de kurdes un jour
symbolique il y a huit ans le 9 janvier
2013 trois militantes kurt et est
exécuté à paris le conseil démocratique
urd en france les manifestants réclament
justice ils soupçonnent les services
secrets turcs ils président recep tayyip
erdogan d'être derrière cet assassinat
en tant que féministe échos féministe je
me sens concernée par à poursuivre parce
qu'ils arrivent à toutes les femmes du
monde
ce sont des femmes qui ont été assimilés
pour leur prise de l'opposition ont leur
courage pour leur appartenance politique
c'est juste inacceptables après la
meilleure c'est comment été assassiné en
france et n'a pas raté leur dire moi je
me sens concernée par mort de trouille
quand des ressortissants étrangers son
team et son territoire français c'est
aussi une responsabilité diplomatique de
la part du gouvernement de tout faire
pour que l' enquête soit menée
et pour que les assassins soient
retrouvés il est absolument hallucinant
qu'on puisse tuer des personnes sur
notre territoire les étrangers peu
importe leur origine et que l'état ne
passe rien pour ne pas croiser la
politique de
voilà des pays étrangers dont la turquie
dont erdogan un des tentes déchirées et
lacéré ce sont les images massivement
relayé ces derniers jours après
l'évacuation d'un camp de migrants à
grande synthe dans le nord une
évacuation qui remet en lumière cette
pratique son fondement légal clair
l'association solidarity qui vient en
aide à ces migrants interpelle les
pouvoirs publics
reportage kata technique renault parquet
et guimard aussi dans le nord de la
france la situation des exilés a atteint
un point critique à grande synthe dans
la zone du puythouck un camp de migrants
d'environ 350 personnes subit des
évacuations à répétition jusqu'à deux
par semaine après l'intervention des
forces de l'ordre et d'une société de
nettoyage
les tentes sont lacérés et emporté les
affaires mises à labenne oussouye et
certains exilés sont mises à l'abri dans
des centres les autres hommes femmes et
enfants errent dans la boue en plein
hiver dans un camp sans sanitaires des
actions supervisé par la nouvelle
municipalité qui inquiète les associatif
très actif sur la zone hier il ya une
grosse évacuation ça faisait une semaine
qu'elle n'avait pas eu c'est peut-être
pour ça donc il ya eu deux compagnies
différentes de crs mobilisés d'habitude
y en a qu'une
notre équipe a été entouré et ils ont
été filmés ils ont été pris en photo par
les forces de l'ordre avec et sans
masque
ils ont pu bouger qu'à la fin de l'hiver
à la fin de l'évacuation aller voir un
petit peu ce qui avait été fait mais on
vraiment ils ont vraiment pas pu
observer en 2021 il ya des gens qui
vivent dans les bois quoi il ya des gens
qui vivent dans la boue on demande aux
pouvoirs publics qu'ils agissent comme
il aurait dû le faire depuis longtemps
bibeau szendy un des exilés originaire
du kurdistan irakien
présent dans le camp depuis un an et
demi raconte ces évacuations
il est traduit par un associatif donc il
dit qu' ils viennent via leur compte ils
lui disent allez il faut partir et
prendre ses affaires
hélas pas le temps de récupérer quoi que
ce soit que il est déjà tout ça va très
très vite et il est épuisé que tout le
temps il doit dormir mais
et toujours faire attention que le matin
ils viennent pas pour effet de partir
avant eux
il aspire à gagner la grande-bretagne
pays où il était plus simple jusqu'ici
d'obtenir des papiers et du travail lui
son quotidien c'est de dormir une heure
ou deux par nuit parce que la part que
la police vienne
ils doivent attendre la journée à avoir
à manger de recharger leur téléphone
voilà son quotidien c'est dresser ici
d'attendre cars and lui aussi kurdes
d'irak explique qu'il a fui son pays
pour des raisons politiques et subit
aujourd'hui une situation dramatique
c'est dur psychologiquement à vivre
quand surtout quand il pleut elle qu'ils
arrachaient tente et on n'est même pas
encore sorti de deux de nos tentes et on
peut même récupérer ils s'indignent
d'une situation aussi cruel qu'il
logique c'est vraiment des filles
surtout pour les familles de rester ici
étant des salles est parfait que les
personnes et font passer les parfums de
cliquer ans éléphants passent en
angleterre
alertée par cette situation délétère les
eurodéputés verts karima delli et damien
carême ont fait le déplacement
ce dernier ancien maire de grande synthe
est connu pour s'être dressés contre
l'état pour offrir des conditions
d'accueil plus digne aux exilés mais la
nouvelle municipalité ne suis pas à
cette voie sur place les visiteurs sont
choqués on voit bien que les évacuations
il y en a eu je crois 85,87 l'année
dernière ne servent à rien mais ça fait
des années qu'on le dit ayant un minimum
d'humanité dans notre action politique
dans l'action publique en france
en permettant à ces personnes de vivre
dignement et pas comme des animaux en
attendant ces sous-bois c'est une
stratégie de l'état d'un visibiliser le
problème en essayant de départ plié il
joue aussi sur l'épuisement des
associations et et l'europe et je vous
passe à son rôle de solidarité ne joue
pas son sens de solidarité et les états
membres se recroqueville carrière des
postures extrémistes il ya quand même un
cadre légal on n'a pas le droit dans une
collectivité de laisser des gens comme
ça on voit médecins du monde qui nous
disent qu'à la galicie la gale elle peut
se répandre à toute la population donc
la collectivité doit prendre des mesures
pour empêcher l'épidémie dont cas de la
loi respecter un rapport de chercheurs
notent que certains pays d'europe ont
recours à la détention illégale des
exilés et l
or que les températures baissent la
politique migratoire européenne et
française continue à patiner au
détriment de la dignité des exilés et 34
ong ont décidé de saisir la défenseure
des droits sur la situation des migrants
en france
médecins du monde action contre la faim
emmaüs france ou encore la ligue des
droits de l'homme dénoncent la
dégradation des conditions des exilés
sans abri à paris en ile de france
une situation alarmante selon le fus qui
dure depuis près de cinq ans il en
appelle donc à claret donc chargé de
défendre les droits des citoyens
les signataires réclament notamment le
droit en hébergement d'urgence la
situation des exilés ne cesse de se
dégrader avec des campements qui se
succèdent dans des conditions sanitaires
et humanitaire toujours plus inquiétante
aujourd'hui ces personnes à la rue ont
perdu pour certaines leur matériel de
première nécessité lors des évacuations
des campements et sont dans une errance
permanentes elles se retrouvent toutes
confrontées comme après chaque
évacuation à une pression policière liée
à la volonté d'empêcher la
reconstitution des campements et
président de la ligue des droits de
l'homme dans le xviiie arrondissement de
paris thomas berteigne à ton de cette
saisine qu'elle fasse bouger les lignes
là aujourd'hui le gouvernement souhaite
que les demandeurs d'asile party d'île
de france souhaite créer 3000 places en
résumant en france pour héberger des
demandeurs d'asile est une des premières
régions qui va être désengorgée sera
l'île de france il va y avoir une
coordination qui est mise en place la
maintenant en janvier par rapport à ça
les 34 associations qui ont signé cette
saisine ne sont pas conviés à 7 à cette
coordination alors que ça fait cinq ans
qu'on travaille sur le terrain en
maraude en équipes mobiles médicalement
et on aimerait bien que cette
coordination puisse se dérouler dans des
conditions correctes et qui respecte les
droits des exilés donc voilà on espère
beaucoup de choses on espère que ça va
enfin changer les choses ça fait ça fait
cinq ans que la situation est comme ça
que ça soit dans le nord à calais ou
apprendre comme on vient de le voir que
ce soit à la roya et malheureusement
aussi en ile de france
donc ces trois régions ça fait cinq ans
qu'on est dans un processus répétées de
d'évacuation qui tous les deux trois
mois on retrouve les mêmes personnes qui
sont évacués qui sont vos amis dans des
gymnases qui ressort dans la rue ça fait
cinq ans que ça dure donc on espère
enfin qu' un changement qui va être
amorcées que défenseur des droits pourra
aider dans ce changement en centrafrique
les résultats de la présidentielle sont
toujours contesté plusieurs recours ont
été déposés
la situation est très tendue et les
groupes armés font craindre le pire
on dit que la musique adoucit les moeurs
et fort de ce constat que la rappeuse
cool faua a décidé d'oeuvrer pour
l'intérêt de son pays
reportage pas compangie et graal taya
c'est une femme souriante et déterminée
qui s'avance dans les rues de bangui
avec son groupe d'une gare alba il
prépare un événement tout particulier là
bas au lieu du concert 93 sortie
officielle de notre premier album un
album du 19e titre prenant
essentiellement la réconciliation et
dénonçant la mainmise des groupes armés
sur le recrutement des enfants
je me sens très très bien et je suis
prêt pour de marboz avec le coup d'état
et la prise de pouvoir de lasser les cas
en 2013
ayant entraîné la guerre entre les
communautés chrétienne et musulmane
la jeune femme a tout perdu beaucoup de
gens le climat qui m'a aidée que moi ont
conseillé de faire la musique de faire
du rap ça me plaisir pour moi parce que
aujourd'hui on me reconnaît en tant que
artistes en rappeuse centrafricains sont
si des la crise que traverse son pays la
jeune femme s'est d'abord lancer dans le
rap pour dénoncer les violences des ex
rebelles
un choix qui a failli lui coûter la vie
elle est aujourd'hui la seule femme du
pays à se frotter à ce milieu très
masculin du rap cooldowns savez c'est
une fille déterminée élevé les nous
rejoint donc et avec ses motivations en
allant l'accepté on fait la musique
engagée
c'est à dire on dénonce un fils c'est
qu'ils ne passent pas de bien dans le
pays donc on est là pour dénoncer koun
fao a rejoint le groupe ga akbar un nom
à la symbolique forte c'est celui de la
prison principale du pays réputé pour
ses conditions d'incarcération difficile
c'est le grand soir le poing levé pour
déclamer ses textes et faire passer ses
messages
l'artiste très féminine à l'instar des
rappeuse américaine actuelle et ses
acolytes donne tout pour leurs fans qui
en ressortent conques il
message qui aide les jeunes qui m'ont
réalise les jeux à contribuer et à
oeuvrer à se mobiliser pour la paix pour
le retour de la peur en insérant un
groupe aux allures de porte-parole qui a
choisi de mettre en lumière une femme
symbole d'émancipation et vecteur
d'espoir pour toute une génération de
jeunes filles centrafricaine l
inquiétude en indonésie ch la compagnie
sriwijaya a perdu le contact avec l'un
de ses appareils peu après son décollage
au dessus de la mer à de java un boeing
b737 qui effectué un vol intérieur de
jakarta à pontiac 62 personnes à bord de
l'avion 50 passagers dont 10 enfants et
un équipage de 12 membres des bateaux
font été déployés sur le site du
probable crash selon les médias locaux
des débris auraient été repérés par les
pêcheurs et non loin de la dernière
position connue de l'appareil et c'est
la fin de cette édition prochain j'étais
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois comment on peut expliquer que
l'un groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi dégradée